[Music]
my name is roger preston
i am the ceo of tresol biofuels
and we have a project with the canary of
islands which
uh we received some sea capital to do a
feasibility study
and the project is ocean retriever
my vision was to get rid of two huge
issues
one was the uh sending plastic waste to
landfill
and two was to sort of make a a
clean burning fuel
for cars for bows for trains and now for
planes
i was invited through the ipp
and euro quitting which i also joined
which i believe were in uh
in league with the ie pp
um a clean tech competition
which was uh based in barcelona spain
i was taught how to sort of promote
myself have to do
a proper pitch
so now i'm looking for the second stage
of funding which will
uh be able to sort of build uh
my project which is the ocean retriever
sort of
uh production of hydrogen ship
that will go to the canary islands
and visit each one and collect all the
plastic from each island
i've had a lot of people contacting me
through the ipp
i've met a lot of
venture capitalists and also companies
wanting
to get involved in the project so
i would highly recommend it
you